Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft hat
ihr letztes Freundschaftsspiel vor der WM
gewonnen.
Das 2:1 gegen Saudi-Arabien war allerdings
glanzlos.
Bundestrainer Joachim Löw sagte nach dem
Match am Freitag in Leverkusen:
"Wenn man es auf den Punkt bringen will: Eigentlich
haben wir zu viele Chancen ausgelassen und
zu viele Chancen zugelassen vom Gegner.
In denke, wir haben gut angefangen.
Erste Halbzeit war gut, unser Spiel nach vorne
war sehr agil, sehr beweglich und gekrönt
von einigen sehr gut herausgespielten Chancen.
In der zweiten Halbzeit haben wir nachgelassen,
unsere Spielweise, haben dann auch viel mehr
Räume dem Gegner gelassen.
Wir hatten mehr Ballverluste, kamen viel weniger
zum Abschluss und von daher hatte der Gegner
dann einfach auch zu viel Platz und zu viel
Raum in diesem Spiel, um selber zu Torchancen
zu kommen."
Unverständnis äußerte Löw zum Verhalten
einiger Fans, die den deutschen Nationalspieler
Ilkay Gündogan bei jedem Ballkontakt ausgepfiffen
hatten.
Gündogan und sein Teamkollege Mesut Özil
hatten sich im Mai in London mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten Recep Tayyip Erdogan getroffen,
das stieß bei vielen Fans auf teils scharfe
Kritik.
"Ich kann es auch schwer nachvollziehen, dass
es so ist, weil der Ilkay hat sich jetzt mehrfach
eigentlich auch den Medien gestellt, der Öffentlichkeit
gestellt, er hat gesprochen.
Das was ich gehört habe diese Woche in Eppan,
dass er nochmals auch in der Öffentlichkeit
gesagt, was er uns schon gesagt hat, beim
Verband oder den Trainern oder dem Oliver,
auch seinen Mitspielern, dass er sich absolut
mit den Werten von Deutschland und mit den
Werten, die wir hier leben identifiziert,
dass er keine politische Botschaft senden
wollte.
Und ich denke, wenn ein Spieler das dann auch
sagt und es mehrfach sagt, dann ist es irgendwann
auch einfach mal gut."
Nun soll alle Konzentration auf die WM gerichtet
werden.
Das Turnier in Russland beginnt am kommenden
Donnerstag.
Deutschland spielt sein erstes Match am 17.
Juni gegen Mexiko.